hey everyone welcome to skip rewind the
shoe that goes over what that he was
I've done this week and also a little
bit of SCP themed news so this week I
have been very busy you wouldn't really
think it if you were looking at my
channel over the past week but I have
been working on scp-914 and its
associated experiment logs which has
taken a very long time I've posted about
this on the community second in my
channel but just bear with me I digress
let's get into the first video that I
uploaded this week was the man who stole
Christmas this is an SCP Christmas
themed and a comedy short teal and I
read this as scp-049
I tried to make the visuals look like a
Christmas story time thing I'm probably
gonna be doing that again closer to
Christmas a few other little short
Christmas stories read by 0 for 9 I plan
on doing these more next week so if you
like that you can look forward to that
the second it is a video but it was it
was a live stream where I pretty much
role played as scp-049 and answered
questions mostly they're mostly silly
questions but you know well it was good
fun you can check out that stream if you
really want in the stream itself the
chat is embedded in the actual video so
you can see what I was responding to you
know on how many people were actually
listening to the stream at the time it's
probably the most successful stream I've
ever done it was the closest I've ever
got to 100 people simultaneously
watching at once so that was pretty cool
the third one was kind of a silly video
but it was actually submitted by the
head mod on my discord shared out the
witness as it go she sent me this script
and it was based on a conversation we
had it made me laugh so much so I just
decided to record it and make it kind of
like a fake
SCP document I thought it was pretty
funny if you haven't seen it give it a
wee lesson if you like
absurdist SC PBS humor I realize that is
a very niche but yeah check it out if he
elected and then finally we have scp-173
the sculpture know whenever i uploaded
this video I uploaded the thumbnail with
art of scp-173 but there is as everybody
knows there is so much legal tip
surrounding the likeness of 173 but I
took down the original one and just
stripped it of pretty much all visuals
of the statue itself because basically I
don't want a zoo me kiddo soon me yeah
so yeah it was very short I I know it
was very short it's just 914 is taken so
long let's take it up so much of my time
I have to upload other shorter videos to
kind of keep people interested in my
channel because you know I've I've
kick-started my channel over the last
two months and I've got a considerable a
Midas theme going now and I don't want
to lose that steam so if you ever see
very short videos or short documents I'm
just trying to keep people interested
whilst I'm working on bigger projects so
yeah but that's what happened there and
that's why I'm uploading shorter things
okay so that's all the videos that I've
done this week there will have been
notification cards at the start of every
announcement I just made so check those
out let's move on to the news okay this
week it's not really news it's just more
things that I find interesting on the
SCP reddit the first thing that I seen
that I thought was pretty interesting
was guy called DJ cactus I think that's
how you hit DJ kak tu yes DJ cactus he
has something really cool that he's
starting I think I'm giving him a big
plug here I find it quite interesting
basically what it is he is starting a
series at the minute where he looks at
an SCP and figures ID what he dislikes
about it an attempt to fix it
and uploads an abridged version of that
SCP and the NCP that he done this week
that caught my attention was scp-049 he
posted this to the SCP reddit it was a
link to his blog called deconstruction
to the life and times of scp-049 it's
long so I can't read it all here because
I'm trying to keep this as short as
possible but he goes through the entire
document describes what he likes and
what he doesn't like a man at the end he
posts on his own like sandbox website
and this is called scp-049 rewrite I
asked him in the reddit comments if I
could actually read this and he gave me
permission to so maybe maybe not no but
but next year Christmas is a busy time
but next year I'm definitely gonna try
and read this it's very interesting I'm
gonna post the link night just to spread
a wee bit of awareness about it but it's
a quatre version of scp-049 so if you
want to read it go read it ok so next up
this isn't really news at but it's a
very interest in theory that was posted
to the SCP reddit and that is scp-682 is
ummat the ancient egyptian entity known
as the devourer of souls now i seen this
first and kind of ruled my eyes like ok
but one of you actually investigate like
the similarities between is 682 visually
anyway i haven't actually looked at the
text or anything of about what the
mythology behind Amun is but I thought
it was pretty pretty interesting because
all the the kind of depictions of of
Armit I hope I'm saying that right but
the art that depicts vomit is very
reminiscent of sexier - I'm not
personally a fan of given sex yet - you
mean but most people do for some reason
but yeah the more the more I thought
about it the more I think that would be
quite cool if that was like a common
thing sexy r2 was an ancient Egyptian
entity though it seems fitting anyway
let me let me know what you think in the
comments I just kind of like itthere
theories that you don't really hear that
often I've never heard a theory like
that before
ok so next up this is definitely news
very topical this is a
a post on the reddit called in case we
lose net neutrality download the wiki
with HT track I think we should all do
that because if if net neutrality goes
ahead it's pretty unlikely that that the
site's gonna go down you know but it's
good to have backups that everybody can
have so so we could in theory see if
their CP wiki if it ever goes down and
preserve it I haven't done it yet
because I've been just so busy this week
but I'm probably I'm gonna do it in the
next week just trying to spread
awareness about that and finally this
kind of relates to my week to last week
the gentleman that developed scp-303 SCP
has launched his own game development
studio called thermal games
Samael games I don't know how to provide
stuff properly please let me know in the
comments so that looks pretty
interesting this is elugu right right
here I still haven't played three zero
zero at the game I know I said I was
going through last week but I'm just I'm
just working so hard to try and give you
as much content as possible
a 914 is kicking my ass Dominika if you
have any questions for me don't hesitate
to put them in the comments below next
week because it's Christmas might be a
little bit hectic but I have at least
two videos planned for like around
Christmas Eve Christmas Day so look
forward to them at least I'm not sure if
I'm gonna be able to make a skip rewind
this time next week for obvious reasons
so if I do you post a skip rewind this
time next week it will most likely be
pre-recorded just to give you a fair
warning from that okay Oh mom I promise
I'm gonna get better at this soonerlater
it's still a work in progress right now
thank you for listening thank you for
your patience
I will see y'all next week bye